ازمينا لدى حجازي نزلت الى الشارع واجرت
تجربه اجتماعيه وسالت الناس عن رايهم في
مضمون كلام ياسمين العزه عن الرجل نسمع
كبير حول تصريحات ياسمين عز واراها في
العلاقه بين الرجل والمراه لمتنتي على
جوزك كده يا محمد حازم مثلا
جوزك يا استاذ محمد
يا استاذ محمد تحب تشرب ايه اكيد شفتي
التصريحات الاخيره لياسمين عز اكيد
الرجاله على الستات وده غلط اصلا احنا
برده لنا ان احنا المفروض بقى لنا رايي
وهمم لنا حاجه في المجتمع مش مش لازم يعني
هو يمشيني هو يحترمني وانا هاحترمه
[موسيقى]
طول الوقت
الاستاذ
بيقولوا لي يا كتكوتي وجات علي انا هاقول
له يا استاذ ههه
يا استاذه وانت تقولي لي يا استاذه ان هو
احنا متجوزين بقى عشان نحطه على القاب
اعمل جوزها محطتين
بيرضي الله انا ست حجه وعارف ربنا
وايجالها بما يرضي الله يمشي مع جوز على
الحلوه والمره صح ولا لا
شويه بس اهو يعني
[موسيقى]
طبعا الست تفكر الراجل وتحترم الراجل
وبرده الراجل يحترم الست طول ما هم
محترمين بعضهم يا بنتي هيبقوا كويسين
[موسيقى]
خالص